[Music]
[Applause]
rebecca lowe is back with us the
presenter of nbc's sports group's
premier league coverage including pre
and post-match show
premier league live well let's recap
where we were
yesterday at this time rebecca and where
we are now with the premier league
dan can i just say the power of the dan
patrick show thank you
if you get me on every day this week
then we can make some progress
and we've already done it it's gone um
well the recap is that this time
literally yesterday i was sat in this
very chair talking to you
and it looked like the end of football
in europe as we knew it in terms of
competitive edge competition
with the big six in england breaking
away and joining the likes of
ac milan into milan juventus real madrid
barcelona
creating this new european super league
however
when we were talking yesterday i
explained to you about the absolute
uproar and the backlash from everybody
all the fans from
everybody involved in the sport i could
not find and i searched for
one person who thought that this was a
good idea and would you believe
i think i mentioned on the show
yesterday that i had been told that
chelsea
and manchester city were starting to
wobble that was 24 hours ago
and they were the first to i think city
officially were the first club to say
we made a mistake we're out and then it
was like a deck of cards
and all six english clubs slowly but
surely throughout the course of
yesterday
all issued statements and said ah um
yeah mistake we're actually thinking it
was not the best idea
we're not going to be in the european
super league we're out and it's now
down to two clubs real madrid
just hanging on in there for that money
and i'm fine with that they get to play
for the championship
every year it's a home and away schedule
it's not confusing at all
uh now do you see other teams in the
premier league
that the six have bowed out is there
anybody else that might step up
or is this done do you think when it
comes to the premier league
i think it's done dan it's done because
as much as i adore the other 14 clubs
and one of my clubs is one of those 14
they are not quite the ratings driver
they are not
the big big boys i mean leicester city
west ham fans will be shouting at their
televisions at the moment or their
radios if i say that because they're
doing really well this season but
that traditional big six it was really
about those
there isn't really a european super
league for the likes of burnley and and
west brom and crystal palace there just
isn't so
i think it's dead it's over it's done
the big question down though now
is it was so damaging in that short
period of time
to reputations to integrity to honesty
within the game
how do we stop this ever happening again
and ever getting so
close to the edge who applied the
pressure that led to this
i think it's the fans i think a
combination of the fans and the media
but i'm going to give the credit to the
fans because the fans
created the ferrari which the media then
reported on
um and plenty of high profile figures
within the game as well gary neville a
former manchester united player hugely
high profile in the uk on british
television he went very very strong
very very early and he kind of began it
in a way
but the fans it was the fans they turned
up outside the chelsea game last night
with banners saying please pull out they
turned up at the liverpool game they
drove from liverpool down to leeds
on monday to to um to protest their own
club and it wasn't even the
fans of the other 14 clubs who would
have been also really badly affected by
this it was the fans of the clubs
themselves and i think that's key
i don't think the owners realized that
that their own
fans they probably knew everybody else
would be mad at them i don't think they
realize
their own fans they don't want to go and
play real madrid every week they want to
play stoke city
they want to play burnley football club
that's the essence of english football
so
for me the fans have won the day and how
many times can we say that in sport not
many times
i understand the idea of this i
understand the money and it's all about
the money
but it felt like it was too drastic like
they were trying to do this in a
clandestine way
late night sunday night you sort of leak
this out and then you go wait a minute
and it almost feels like it it was too
far down the road for somebody or
someone's to object to but i give i give
the fan base
credit and those who came to their
senses here
and i don't want these owners who say
hey we did the right thing you know we
pulled out no
you were gonna do the wrong thing you
were gonna do this i'm not gonna give
you
credit for something like this oh damn
don't you worry the english media will
not allow the owners to forget what they
did i can promise you that i've read
enough articles already saying let's
just hold on
off on the credit for the owners uh
let's remember what they
almost did but the clandestine way they
did it as you say
i think that's what hurts so many people
within the game because it came out of
nowhere
it was all done totally secretly and
that's the damage that now has to be
repaired because let's now remember down
these six are now kind of
coming back to the premier league with
their tails between their legs saying
oh we made a mistake can we play can we
just play like we were playing before
can we just be friends like we were
before and how
the fans are going to react to those
clubs how other chairmen and other
owners are going to react
a huge amount of damage has been done
the trust has been lost
that has to be rebuilt and that has to
be rebuilt
by the owners of those six clubs and
nobody else okay so now i can move
on to some other things in uh the uk
like harry and the queen mom and
uh you know prince william like do you
want me to go there like i can
i can start there i can you know brexit
what do you want me to do rebecca
i am your english correspondent so i'm
very much hoping for any subject matter
with regards to you tell me what you'd
like to talk about
and i'm here for you you know what i did
think about
this is strange when i first heard what
was happening with the super league
the person i thought of the one person i
thought of when they
were talking about this and then the
fallout when they all collapsed
can you can you think of the one person
that i would have
that i would have in my weird sick sense
of humor
this is who i thought of ted lasso
you got you know season two of ted lasso
coming up and i thought how would ted
lasso
deal with this because he's always in a
good mood
and i wonder what he would think of the
super league
i i think to be honest i wouldn't be
surprised if ted lasso hadn't been the
one that's orchestrated this giant
crumble because i feel that ted lasso
can heal the
world and i think you agree with me with
that dan what a man
what a series and i mean we had him on
the show years ago when it all started
and
jason's a daikis i mean the guy is an
absolute genius that show
is a show which in this very time right
now 2020 2021
we need ted lasso yes
when the when season one was over i was
sad
i don't know the last time i've been sad
when a season you know when you're
watching eight to ten episodes because
he's so positive
it was so much fun it allowed people who
are you know dipping their toes into
soccer because we're sort of like ted
lasso
in some ways you know some of us we're
like uh uh
you know what's offsides no seriously
like what is offsides help me out
here so i i'm anxious in july for ted
lasso to come back
i know he is the positive in the world
that we need and i think that he is the
antidote to everything right now that's
partly why it's been so popular because
i agree
it was just escapism and good prevails
ultimately good fail
it does with ted lasso and that's what
we all have to hang on to in life right
i was worried about you yesterday i was
i had not seen you like that
and and it was i could tell like it it
hurt
you know you weren't unhinged but you
would you know the passion was there and
we're supposed to compartmentalize when
when we're on the air we're supposed to
you know not
show our emotions and it was like i
could tell that uh it hit you hard
yesterday
it did dan and i think as well i've been
in this
world for nearly 20 years this industry
and and i grew up watching the game it
means a
huge amount to me and it's a huge amount
of every football fan out there it's a
family thing it's a
like i say it's like a religious thing
really football is like that and it's my
career and it's my
it's my whole life really and that felt
under threat yesterday everything that i
loved about my life
separately from my family felt like
could all change and i think we've had
enough of that haven't we since march
2020 when what we knew of life
suddenly changed and i don't want any
more change so
i am i tell you we popped some champagne
last night my husband and i
and we we raised the glass so good good
do you love okay in order you love your
son teddy
and then where's the premier league and
then where's your husband
my husband's just gone out so i can
definitely tell you that
it's all it's it's a huge part of my
life and it's a and i would say the same
and actually
you know most football fans would say
that their
their club winning a trophy is up there
on the same day as their birth of their
first child i mean i
i actually know what one guy who works
in the game who is very proud of the
fact
that he has never been at the birth of
any of his children because and he has a
few children
because he's always been at a football
match on the day that they've been born
he's very proud of that so
that is how deep this game runs in
england
uh i'm i'm probably not going to talk to
you tomorrow
well okay i mean unless something
happens
i'm probably not going to have todd
reach out to you okay
oh oh i get it so you just bring me into
the big story
i gotta bring in i gotta bring in some
royals tomorrow like i got other things
to worry about i fixed this
now i move on oh the dan patrick show
just moving through the world
fixing massive problems i love it just
in europe just in europe
thank you rebecca anytime that's rebecca
lowe
a presenter nbc sports with uh the
premier league coverage uh
pre-post premier league live